the Elon Musk story part one growing up
divorce abuse and bullying
Elon Musk was born on June 28 1971 in
Pretoria South Africa he's the son of a
model and dietician from Saskatchewan
Canada and a South African electro
mechanical engineer pilot and sailor he
has a younger brother
Kimball born in 1972 and a younger
sister
Tosca won in 1974 after his parents
divorced in 1980 musk lived mostly with
his father in the suburbs of Pretoria
musk chose to live with his dad two
years after his parents split up his two
siblings chose to stay with his mom and
he said he felt sorry for his father
because she got all three kids
Ilan thought his father was sad and
lonely by himself and wanted to keep him
company he now says it was not a good
idea he was such a terrible human being
you have no idea my dad will have a
carefully thought-out plan of evil he
will plan evil you have no idea about
how bad almost every crime you can
possibly think of he has done almost
every evil thing you could possibly
think of he has done it's so terrible
you can't believe it in my experience
there's nothing you can do nothing
nothing I wish I've tried everything
I tried threats rewards intellectual
arguments emotional arguments everything
to try to change my father for the
better and he no way no way it just got
worse as an adult musk severed relations
with his father
[Music]
musk was also severely bullied
throughout his childhood and was once
hospitalized when a group of boys threw
him down a flight of stairs a man beat
him until he lost consciousness but the
longest time I was the youngest and
smallest kid in the class because my
birthday just happens to fall on almost
the last day that they will accept you
into school June 28th now is a late
bloomer SARS the youngest and smallest
kid in class for years and years the
gangs at school would hunt me down
literally hunt me down Musk started to
learn how to fight back and took up
karate judo and wrestling
I started dishing it out as hard as
they'd give it to me he got into a fight
with the biggest bully at school and
knocked him down with a single punch the
bully never picked on him again it
taught me a lesson if you're fighting a
bully you cannot appease a bully you
punch the bully in the nose
bullies are looking for targets that
won't fight back if you make yourself a
hard target and punch the bully in the
nose he's going to beat out of you but
he's actually not going to hit you again
during his childhood musk was an avid
reader at age 10 he developed an
interest in computing with the Commodore
vic-20 he taught himself computer
programming at the age of 12 sold the
code of a basic based video game he
created called
blast star to a magazine called PC and
office technology for approximately $500
a web version of the game is available
online his childhood reading included
Isaac Asimov's foundation series from
which he drew the lesson that you should
try to take the set of actions that are
likely to prolong civilization minimize
the probability of a Dark Age and reduce
the length of a Dark Age if there is one
he moved to Canada in June 1989 just
before his 18th birthday
after obtaining a Canadian passport
through his Canadian born mother his
father didn't blast the move he said
rather contentiously that I'd be back in
three months that I'm never going to
make it and that I'm never going to make
anything of myself he called me an idiot
all the time that's the tip of the
iceberg by the way musk was accepted
into Queens University in Canada after
spending two years at Queen's he
transferred to the University of
Pennsylvania where he received a
Bachelor of Science degree in physics
and a Bachelor of Science degree in
economics Musk extended his studies for
one year to finish the second bachelor's
degree while at the University of
Pennsylvania musk and fellow Penn
student a day or se rented a 10 bedroom
fraternity house using it as an
unofficial nightclub in 1995 at age 24
musk moved to California to begin a PhD
in applied physics and materials science
at Stanford University but left the
program after two days to pursue his
entrepreneurial aspirations in the areas
of the Internet
renewable energy in outer space he had
big dreams and it was time to bet on
himself raise your standard Apple cool
its core value is that
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something serene in part two
of the Elon Musk's story we talked about
how he went from dropping out of
university to start in his first
business raising the angel capital
around it and ultimately building a
business that he would sell for over a
billion dollars go check out part 2 of
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and see you there